j'étais voix hereafter burrier puis une
trace et sa maman il est morte
nous sommes le 5 décembre 1959
trois jours plus tôt à 21h13 exactement
des pluies diluviennes s'abattent sur la
région du var la ville de fréjus et
soudain plongé dans le noir puis un
énorme grondement se fait entendre
le barrage de malpasset construit cinq
ans plus tôt à céder le barrage a été
littéralement éventrée par les 50
millions de mètres cubes d'eau l'énorme
vague à rouler vers la petite localité
endormi à 80 kilomètres à l'heure
emportant tout sur son passage tout sur
son passage dans des centaines de vies
humaines bilan total 423 morts mais
quelques jours après la catastrophe
le recensement n'est encore que
partielle le désastre humain est
effrayant
plus de trois cent cinquante cadavres
arraché à l'abri la ville ressemble à un
véritable champ de bataille et les
témoignages des rescapés son glaçon la
maison trembler de tous les côtés et
nous sommes restés dans le grenier toute
la nuit
deezer d'état à entendre et sentir
bouger le moulin et le materne ou crié
courage courage vous avez tenu jusqu'à
maintenant vous tiendra encore des
dégâts matériels sont considérables les
réseaux d'eau et d'électricité sont
détruits comme des centaines
d'habitations et de fermes
ou encore 1600 mètres de voies ferrées
les doigts fut de tous y compris des
artistes comme le relève pierre tchernia
présentateur de l'eau et recueille
maintenant nous arrive des nouvelles des
théâtres de paris
et ce n'est pas étonnant bien sûr tous
les artistes ont voulu se solidariser au
total 9 milliards d'anciens francs ont
été récoltés
l'élan de solidarité touche même l'armée
américaine qui vient en aide aux
sinistrés
ravitaillement en eau et nourriture
vaccinations campagne de dératisation
peu à peu la solidarité est de fréjus à
se reconstruire le ce mercredi l'
angoisse se dissipe l'énergie et le
courage des sauveteurs et des survivants
sont quelque chose d'admirable fréjus
travail et se retrouve en pensant ses
plaies et souvenir est fort dans la
mémoire collective des habitants de la
région qui commémore chaque année le
drame
cinquante ans plus tard marie-christine
en garde un souvenir très précis quand
on était pris pour moi c'était la guerre
la guerre
sans intérêt si les termes et les
internes en collectif un procès sera
ouvert mais aucun coupable ne sera
désigné
l'ingénieur du projet quant à lui se
suicidera six mois après l'événement
la rupture du barrage de malpasset
restera l'une des plus grandes
catastrophes civile du 20e siècle
[Musique]